globalization today is not just the
spread of products and ideas and money
and even people around the world it's
also about the arrangements that are
made by companies to start operating in
new countries to open up new factories
and plants and service operations when
companies do those things they typically
need middlemen to help them enter those
new markets and those middlemen can have
a variety of different occupations you
need translators you need lawyers who
can help you to adapt to a new legal
system you need accountants because
there are always new accounting systems
and regulations too you need fixers who
can help you to find locations for your
new operation help you to deal with
local officials you need a whole variety
of people who are middlemen because they
operate between the foreign companies
coming in and all of the domestic actors
whether they be governments or companies
or citizens groups on the ground this is
truly important for globalization now
where do these middlemen get their
return well they usually get paid a fee
upfront because the company is entering
the new market saying hey there is some
value to our being here and we're
willing to pay a small percentage of
that value to the people who help us to
open our operation and that small
percentage is what the middlemen receive
they get that upfront payment if you're
a middleman this is fantastic because
you can help one company to open an
operation in a new country and then you
can help another company and another and
each time you're going to get that
little percentage of the total value of
that company's engagement with that new
country now middlemen have lots of
opportunities here they could specialize
in a sector you could work only with
companies in oil and gas industries they
could specialize in a country you can
say we're going to be the law firm for
any American company that wants to enter
Ghana for example there are many ways
that they could structure their business
and economists have found that they are
able to get this significant upfront
payment you could say well isn't this
damaging doesn't this take money away
from the company and from the people on
the ground who might have benefit who
might have benefited from the company's
operations there well not really because
there had to be some sort of opening of
the gates to allow these companies to
come in and this is what the middlemen
provide
in the long term it's good for the
economies on both sides